so we have an infinite series here and
the goal of this video is to try to
figure out the interval of convergence
for this series and that's another way
of saying for what x values what what
range of x values is this series going
to converge and like always pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
so when you look at this series it
doesn't fit cleanly into something like
a geometric series or an alternating
series when i see something like this i
think about the ratio test because it
tends to be pretty general and to apply
the ratio test we want to think about
the limit
the limit as n
approaches infinity of
the n plus one term divided by the nth
term and the absolute value of that
and if this thing is less than one
so when this thing is less than one
then
we are going to converge
and the x values that make this thing
greater than 1 we are going to diverge
and the x values that make this equal to
1 well then we are going to be
inconclusive and so we're gonna have to
use other techniques to think about
whether we're going to
converge or diverge so let's just think
about this let's just evaluate this so
let's do that limit
as n approaches infinity
of the absolute value of a sub n plus 1
well that's going to be x to the n plus
1. let me color code this just so we
know what we're doing so this thing
right over here is going to be
x to the n plus 1
over
n plus 1 times 5 to the n plus 1 and
we're going to divide that by
the nth term we're going to divide that
by the nth term and that's just going to
be x to the n
over
n times 5 to the n
and we're going to take the absolute
value of this whole thing
now let me simplify this i'll simplify
it down here so this is the same thing
as
x to the n plus one
over
n plus one times five to the n plus one
times
the reciprocal of this so it's going to
be n
times 5 to the n
over x to the n and we could simplify
this this is going to be equal to
let's see you divide numerator
denominator by x to the n you're left
with just an x
and then divide numerator and
denominator by 5 to the n
that is going to be that's a 1 this is a
1 and then this is just going to be 5 to
the n plus 1 divided by 5 to the n
that's just going to be a 5.
and so what do we have we have x times n
x
times
n
over
distribute the five
five n
plus one oh let me be careful there let
me distribute the five five n
plus
5. 5 times n 5 times 1. 5n plus 1. 5 5n
plus 5.
all right so let me just rewrite that
this is going to be equal to
the limit
as n approaches infinity of the absolute
value of
this thing and actually to help us with
this limit let me rewrite it a little
bit let me divide the numerator and the
denominator both by n i'm not changing
the value i'm doing the same thing to
the numerator and the denominator i'm
dividing it by the same value so if i
divide the numerator and denominator by
n this is this is going to be the same
thing as
x
over
plus
5 to the n and so when i divide the
numerator and denominator by n it
becomes very clear what happens as n
approaches infinity as n approaches
infinity x doesn't change 5 doesn't
change but 5 over n goes to 0. and so
this limit is going to be equal to x
over 5.
so that's a pretty neat clean thing so
now we can use this to think about
actually let me write this this is going
to be the absolute value of x over 5.
and so now we can think about under
which conditions is the absolute value
of x over five going to be less than one
and we're going to definitely converge
under what conditions are we going to be
greater than one and definitely diverge
and then on what conditions is it
inconclusive so let's just see when we
know we can converge so the absolute
value of x over 5
is less than 1 this is our convergence
situation well that's the same thing as
saying that
x
negative 1 is
less than x over 5
which is
less than 1 and you multiply all the
sides by 5 this is the same thing as
negative 5
is less than x which is less than 5. so
if we know that this is true this is
definitely going to be part of the
interval of convergence we know that if
x meets these constraints then our
series is going to converge but we're
not done yet we have to think about the
inconclusive case so let's think about
the scenario where the absolute value of
x over 5
absolute value of x over 5 is equal to
1. or another way of thinking about this
this means the that means x over 5 is
equal to 1 or
x over 5 is equal to negative 1 and this
means that x is equal to 5
or
x is equal to
negative 5. so these are the two
inclusive cases using the ratio test so
let's test them out individually by
looking back at the series and just
substituting x equals 5 or x equals
negative 5. so in the first scenario let
me find a new color here
let me use red so the first scenario of
x equals 5. let's go to our series then
the series is going to be
the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of 5
to the n
over n
times 5 to the n
well this is just going to be equal to
the sum
n equals 1 to infinity
of 1 over n and this is a harmonic
series this is the p series where p is
equal to one and we know for p series if
p is equal to one that's going to
diverge so this and we know the harmonic
series we've done in other videos this
definitely diverges so this diverges and
you can do that by p series convergence
test if the p for a p series is one well
you're going to diverge so now let's
think about so five is definitely not
part of its inter part of our interval
of convergence nothing but x equals
negative five when x equals negative 5
let me get another color going here
when x is equal to negative 5 then this
thing is going to be equal to
the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of negative
5 to the n
and actually let me just write that as
i'll write it out negative 5 to the n
over
n times 5 to the n this is the same
thing as the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity of we could
write this as negative 1 to the n
times 5
to the
times
5 to the n
over n times 5 to the n
and now this thing this is an
alternating harmonic series and so you
could actually use the we you might
already know that that converges or you
could use the heart you could use the
alternating series test and the
alternating series test it might be a
little bit clearer if i write it like
this
that this is an alternating series
so in an alternating series test if we
see
if we see that this thing
is monotonically decreasing and the
limit as n approaches infinity is zero
this thing converges the alternating
harmonic series actually converges so
this converges
so given that this converges you could
view this as this boundary here we would
include that in our interval of
convergence so x doesn't just have to be
strictly greater than negative 5 it
could be greater than or equal to
negative 5 but it has to be less than 5.
this is our true
interval of convergence